j'ai demandé un petit peu car avant
avant de partir en pause mais sont pour
moi c'est une légende
franchement je fous du gars je n'ai
jamais rencontré de ma vie luc besson
peut pas blairer
eh bien je pense tu vas encore moins de
bléré après non mais vraiment je suis
fou de ce gars j'ai jamais on voudrait
juste que j'ai dit à franquin de montant
mais j aimerais tu m'as dit que tu
l'appelles parce que je sais que tu as
très très peur de luc besson pour lui
les sens pour manu il dit peu plus
s'appeler emmanuel macron et n'importe
qui que luc besson ce héros pas assez le
taulier c'est le taulier donc tu va
l'appeler je sais qu'on a une carrière
je sais que tu vas lui dire et je vous
jure qu'il est ils n'ont pas prévenu
avant parce que j'étais là et j'ai bien
vérifié qui nous renvoyait au cas texto
hitman italie franck tu l'appelles tu
l'appelles en valeur et m'a dit que tu
lui dis faut que je te parle tout de
suite lui qu on a des choses à voir tous
les deux mais un petit coup de pression
mais que ça va ouais les chiffres ça va
c'est bon ça se passe bien je suis avec
malik là on est on va rentrer sur
château d'hanouna tu sais et il faudrait
qu'on vous voit lui parce que malick il
a des trucs à régler il n'est pas
content je te le passe vite fait je peux
contre à l'eau ou à l'udc
je travaille parce que c'est banon est
cycliquement taxi c'est vrai c'est très
difficile et moi je suis en train de
péter un boulard pourquoi non mais je
suis si j'arrive j'arrive plus j'arrive
plus je voudrais qu'on se voit chez ohb
dans la preuve de sérénité
il a joué là bas il ça va pas en fait il
a besoin de te voir et je crois qu'il a
un petit pétage de plombs d'avant sortie
du film tu pas en train de péter les
plombs
là encore pourquoi n'ont-ils c'est
normalement mais sans déconner je crois
qu'il ne vais pas bien tatata moyens de
venir ici lutte pour pourvoir maliki
commun
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on est on est tellement heureux de voir
enfin nous
en ce moment vous pouvez pas noir non
mais je vous explique j'ai eu sept
minutes de pub pendant sept minutes j'ai
perdu un ami nommé meilleur va venir
maintenant je pense qu'il aurait pu lui
parler de sa vie d'homme et ses roues
pato et sur ma vie ouais vraiment mais
j'étais en panique qui m'a dit appelle
les insultes jets des mesures à faire
insulter le pape dure même pas qu allez
vous aime parce que il l'a fait par
amitié pour vous alors qu'il était
vraiment pas bien pendant la nuit mais
non je tombais dans et moi je pense ça
prouve comment il les respecte beaucoup
mais respectons mais c'est fou luc et
qui il échangeait rendez vous raté jeu
mais prend effet ça secoue